okay so Castlevania Nocturne has just
released on Netflix and there's a lot to
talk about in it if you've been
following the channel for a while and
you know we love the first four seasons
of that original show and I've been
excited to see where this series will go
I'm happy to say it didn't disappoint
and throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down this will explain
its ending talk about all the characters
in it and basically act as a sort of
recap but what goes down in the end
heavy spoilers ahead so if you haven't
checked it out then I highly recommend
that you check out now please hit the
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the
breakdown and don't forget to subscribe
for videos like this every day without
the way huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into Castlevania Nocturne
now we begin in 1783 at Boston
Massachusetts where we meet a young
Rector Belmont too I'm sure you all know
witnessing his mother Julia killed in
front of him by a vampire named allrocks
he picks up her Whip and then swears
Vengeance curtinine years later in the
midst of the French Revolution and only
someone look at a metaphor for the
vampires of society being represented by
the elite now these are actual vampires
in the show but the idea Still Remains
that their parasites which beat up the
poor as we know in real life they come
in fog we're currently waging a war for
equality which actually works quite well
in this class struggle metaphor in the
past series we saw how Dracula lived in
a castle looking down on all and the
vampires have always been a metaphor for
the ruling class this idea of revolution
is seen from the off with the American
Revolution being signed in 1783. it's
such a cool and interesting way to take
things and it Paints the creatures of
the night owl in a brand new light now
we meet Maria who's one of the Mainstays
in the Castlevania series with her first
debuting in Rondo of Blood a distant
relative of the Belmont Clan she shares
a kinship with Richter and sort of
aligns with his vampire hunting goals
now they hear a vampire Messiah is on
the way in this Devourer of life brings
a lot of potential chaos with it which
is what the season revolves around now
this is a character known as is about
battery who will bring an eternal
Eclipse allowing the vampires to exist
at all times of the day this will tip
the scales and create true inequality we
Learners about was a monster even before
she became a vampire with her sick and
sadistic ways now knowing no bounds due
to her immortality Maria's mother Terah
encountered her when she was a child and
in Russia her clan was attacked by
soldiers and vampires capturing her
sister is a bit tortured her for days
rejoicing in the agony that she
inflicted on others now the other major
players in this are the Abbott and as we
learned through the series his daughter
is Maria the Abbott wants vampires to
help fight the rising masses who reject
God and see Faith as being a Folly
Humanity has started to reject religion
and they want to use the resources from
the church to help with their money war
and improving their lives on the
opposite side of this the vampires need
the Abbott because he can transform the
common folk into the night creatures
these are demons made from Human corpses
grafted onto goals directly from Hell
the Abbott is a forge master and we
watch his Rector tries to uncover this
and the vampire Messiah everything
culminates with Rector and it Miss rack
and Tara heading towards the Abbey to
stop Maria being sacrificed mizrak was
an ally of the Abbey but in the end he
had a change of heart as for an air
she's a vampire hunter as well who's
based on her name's sake that becomes
Richter's girlfriend early in the series
she watches Ally at about consumed by
the creatures which brings the themes of
what the characters fight for all of
them have witnessed a loved one ravaged
by the creatures of the night and thus
they want to stop others suffering from
that pain Edward is turned into a beast
him so I'm Gonna Keep butchering the
names it's edible erdoboard but he's
turned into Beast himself and we witness
firsthand how the Machine Works he turns
on his Masters in the end and the series
itself is a metaphor for slavery and
rising up we see this most notably in
episode 6 with Annette speaking to her
ancestors the class struggle is
something that keeps popping up with
with the night creatures even rebelling
against their masters now the idea to
destroy the machine is suggested by
aurox who says they should use a magic
book to send it to hell even all rocks
is rebelling and it leads to some really
interesting Dynamics for the show going
to The Abbey they try and stop it all
but in the end Isabel brings on the
eclipse performing a spell in the wake
of this she's transformed and she
becomes the Egyptian goddess sekhmet she
was known as the deity of war and
Vengeance and was a bloodthirsty being
known for vanquishing her enemies SEC
met bloodlust of course works as a
metaphor for vampire as in the air with
her daily like Powers also making her
akin to the Demon's messiah in the
Legends sekhmet was betrayed by the sun
god raw so it makes sense why she'd want
to create an eclipse that blocks it out
for good now they managed to free Maria
and Tara opens a portal to Hell whilst
Annette goes to push the night creature
machine into it you also see Miz rat
going against jolta and it's such a cool
way for the season to play out have to
say the action throughout this series is
absolutely incredible with the animation
being so fluid and dynamically
fast-paced really feels like the game
brought to life and the kind of battles
you'd imagine happening in your head
when you used to play those it is 16 and
8-bit games you know but you imagine
them to be massive now jolta proves to
be a really powerful so Maria joins The
Fray with Rector to combat her abilities
though it's somewhat leading towards a
win it doesn't last long and everything
goes paste with ursabet's arrival she
ties with the forces swatting them like
flies and just knocking them out the way
demonstrating her power mizerak is also
taking out the fight by aurox because as
we see he does in fact love him now
during this he says that he doesn't want
misreacted eye however the sentiment
isn't returned and mizra goes back to
The Abbey all rocks has been someone
who's denied his love in the past but we
learn he's even wanted to turn his
lovers into vampires to be with them
forever this is somewhat a form of
slavery as you're turning someone into a
vampire for your own selfish desires I
love the complexity that came from their
relationship and castlevania's always
been great at painting out these complex
characters due to what he does in the
opening we really should hate him but he
aligns with Heroes far more than you'd
think either way it all goes down now we
see his Terror pleads as a bet to take
her instead of her daughter Maria
however the sacrifice here won't involve
death it'll actually involve changing
her into a vampire this of course plays
off of Tara's past with her sister being
turned into one as well because the
Abbott loves her though Terror still
puts herself forward and we see she's
willing to sacrifice it all we're told
that the sacrifice must involve someone
the Abbott loves and thus it's able to
still be carried out how is a bit
infects her while see other people see
the Abbey which hilariously has the
village bulk throwing Rotten Tomatoes at
them this leaves the machine and the
villain at the heart of their powers
meaning that the heroes have truly lost
hunted by the forces of dralter she
moves in to kill Richter but at this
point we get a big returning character
that is Alucard who's here to save the
day and I'm sure you'll instantly
recognize him if you watch the other
seasons alikado is Dracula's son with a
show centering around him and his
vampire hunting allies in the end he
Hobbit villages in his castle and
finally came to terms with the
depression he experienced so cool seeing
him arrive he does look slightly
different but with the eclipse moon
behind him it's hard to hate on it the
shot that pulls together the iconography
of Castlevania perfectly and even just
seeing him twirling his soul around and
warning the rest of the vampires it's
such a cool moment up until this point
the heroes were clearly losing the
battle but now in this moment they
actually stand a chance I feel with him
they're gonna be able to beat irsabat
and finally stop this dark Guard from
destroying it all the series is Loosely
adapting Rondo blood and also alongside
its Symphony of the Night there's still
a lot to cover and I think season 2 will
be going over the the elements of them
both season 4 of the first series shot
as Dracula still alive and Rondo ended
with Richter confronting him directly
come Symphony set in 1796 we saw his
Dracula's castle reappeared which
Alucard started investigating Gary found
Richter who said he was the new Lord and
alongside Maria Alucard try to get to
the bottom of it going forward I think
that will be what Loosely happens though
they might just stick to this main
Messiah story either way there's a lot
to look forward to and it was so cool
seeing the series back I have to say I
really enjoyed it and it's continued to
keep the consistent style that made me
fall in love with the first series
watching the complexities really adds a
lot and even just seeing Richter getting
his headband it was done really well
next time the stakes are really ramped
up though and I think even stuff like
Tara being a vamp is gonna add so much
I'm so glad this universe is here and
it's still going and there's a lot to
love here and places they can go overall
I really enjoyed the show show and
hopefully this has cleared up any
questions you might have had let me know
below along with your thoughts on the
show and also what you think is gonna
happen next time also the singing was
nice as well wasn't it please drop a
like on the video and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button to get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out you want to
get some heavy spoilers merch we've also
got our t-shirt line located below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time one
house of dragon stuff Marvel teaser more
you drop new designs on there all the
time so definitely keep an eye out and
thank you if you bought one now if you
want something else to watch you got a
video on screen right now so definitely
head over there right after this now the
way huge thank you for clicking this
I've been Paul you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
all right